welcome back to New rockstars I'm Eric
Voss and Marvel's Ant-Man the West
Quantum media is now streaming on Disney
plus allowing us to see even more
details in this complicated movie
details that you might have missed the
first time around extra context coming
from the people who made it some
possible answers for why so let's break
down all the new stuff that we found in
quantumania in the Marvel Studios
Fanfare we see he remains from the Logan
finale at the top of the a marking the
first time a villain has been included
in the Marvel Studios opening title card
and yes Marvel is still in a bit of an
awkward spot given Jonathan Majors legal
troubles the jury is still literally out
as of this taping so we won't be wading
into that here but the prologue scene
shows Kang the conqueror's arrival in
the quantum realm after he was banished
by the King Dynasty for starting the
multiversal war notice the sky is
streaked with these streaks of brilliant
purple and teal Kang's signature colors
but three pieces break off of Kang's
ship as it arrives perhaps representing
the three kings who sabotaged the ship
and led to his betrayal Pharaoh Rama
tent immortus and Scarlet Centurion and
yes there may be a connection between
those three times Keepers in the fourth
broken statue from Loki that statue
could represent this exiled Kang now the
screenwriter said the Symmetry was meant
to evoke the fall of the Angel Lucifer
from Heaven into hell inspired by John
Milton's Paradise Lost we could also see
Kang as a Napoleonic figure exiled to
his Elba here but only a temporary exile
before Napoleon's Grand comeback at the
Battle of Waterloo that Waterloo on the
horizon could be Avengers Secret Wars
Janet Van Dyne had been stuck in the
quantum Realms since she shrinked
between atoms to disable a rogue ICBM in
1987. you could see Kang's arrival as
the first indication that Janet was
lying to Hank and hope when she
indicated that she'd been down there
alone all that time alternatively King's
arrival here could be taking place in a
timeline that's been warped by the
events of Loki which would be in a
timeline as skewed from that Nexus
moment and Avengers end game when Loki
escaped with the Tesseract and only now
has the MCU been retconned with Kang's
influence I like the detail of Janet
hurting these horse-like creatures with
snail heads while this movie never
really explains much about the quantum
Realms fauna or evolutionary history I
just like the gag of one of the slowest
animals being mixed with one of the
fastest now the creature that attacks
Janet starts as one entity but then
splits into two this is imagery that
repeats throughout the quantum realm
Kang saves Janet by blasting the
creature right before it pounces on her
and she saves him by showing him the
quantum realm ropes Scott Lang's opening
montage is set to John Sebastian's theme
song for the sitcom Welcome Back Cotter
which is the Callback to the 2018 Hitman
and the WASP openings Montage which was
set to come on get happy which is a
theme song for the sitcom The Partridge
Family they're both very upbeat and
optimistic and up until this point Scott
has been one of the more light-hearted
characters in the MCU often played as
comic relief among the other more
serious Avengers but this film causes
him to confront his own place in things
what responsibility he has to the
greater good in the World At Large and
really step up into the role of an
Avenger and what that really means and
screenwriter has said with Paul red we
had the opportunity to do this throwback
90s dad protagonist the way Robin
Williams and hook are Jumanji feels you
have this playful superhero that most
people think is pretty low stakes and
the pitch we had was what if he's
accidentally in an Avengers movie
basically by himself completely out of
its depth now it gets blocked by a shrub
here but but on the wall is graffiti of
Ant-Man with a heart around it showing
how he's become a bit of a celebrity
like all the loving wall art of Tony
Stark that we saw in Spider-Man far from
home but I also just like the detail
that people this world might not know if
he's alive or dead because they don't
know which of the Avengers died in the
Battle of Earth but Scott is recognized
everywhere he goes now in this
neighborhood which does follow his role
in reversing the blip with the rest of
the Avengers it was his escape from the
quantum realm and at five years time
dilation discovery of time travel's
possibility that really unlocked
everything though really we should give
credit to that rat this is just a funny
development after that scene in end game
where some kids wanted a photo with Hulk
but couldn't care less about Scott now
we know that Miss Marvel established
Scott guessed it on that this powered
Life podcast and now he's branched out
with an autobiography titled look out
for the little guy actually remember his
book tour was teased in Black Panther
were kind of forever you can actually
buy this book on Amazon the first thing
we really get a good look at in this
montage is played by Patricia Belcher
from movies like jeepers creepers and
species she only appears here briefly
which makes me think they probably
filmed more with her but might have had
to cut it for time there was a lot
reworked from this opening section all
the stuff that they shot in this
location it's got high five I was a kid
with an Ant-Man backpack the photo on it
taken directly from 2015 Ant-Man promo
material I am going to assume that this
kid is a young Kang just because I'm
crazy then Scott visits Bridge donuts
with donuts overpriced at three dollars
fifty cents per and all themed around
San Francisco we see the Embarcadero the
summer of love the hate Presidio Pier 39
Golden Gate and the Candlestick Cafe
owner named Reuben is played by actor
Reuben rabassa who played the balloon
vendor Mr Cardozo and nations of Shield
and a little character and Tim Robinsons
I think he should leave uh any other
ideas stinky
what here he says Reuben you are the
best thank you Spiderman
he's clearly confusing Scott with the
other bug branded superhero Scott's
opening narrations referencing his time
traveling with Captain America and
Avengers end game how that didn't make
sense though and Loki we learned that
that was something the Kang variant he
remains wanted them to do what they did
was supposed to happen you escaping was
not FBI agent Jimmy woo returns he and
Scott finally get that lunch date that
they plan at the end of the 2018 movie
yeah it's how you were inviting me
somewhere like a party or like dinner or
something I don't know I thought you
were planned the evening no I meant to
like arrest you I'll arrest you later
again take it easy okay
did you want to grab dinner or something
I mean because I'm free yeah come on we
see Scott doing some sleight of hand to
conjure the credit card we saw in one
division how Jimmy woo picked up Scott's
close-up magic hobby but the bill gets
paid by a different couple a cameo here
by YouTuber Ryan bergara and his wife
Marielle Scott I actually got to cameo
in one of his watcher videos top five
feet down go check it out Watchers an
amazing YouTube channel also among the
early cameos is Mark Everett of the band
eel
Scott and take a photo with this dog
Marcus his son a physicist Hugh Everett
III who was the guy who originally
proposed the mini world's theory of
quantum physics which this movie and
most of Marvel phases 5 and 6 would not
exist without Baskin Robbins boss Dale
returns to the 2015 film shaking Scott's
hand for way too long as the now Awards
him employee of the century using an old
company photo and he kept Scott's pink
apron a name tag Jack which Paul red
actually picked as a shout out to his
son jack this goofy award is also kind
of a running gag with Cassie giving him
world's greatest grandma trophy in the
previous film quantumania is the 31st
movie in the MCU which is a nice bit of
coincidence with the 31 Baskin-Robbin
flavors we see that hope now runs the
Pim Van Dyne foundation and she uses pin
particles for various humanitarian
efforts including food production
reversing deforestation expanding public
housing Scott's vo narration transitions
to him reading aloud from his book at
City Lights Bookstore that's not the
actual City Lights Bookstore in the Bay
Area but that's what they call it here
in the set for this crowd of fans
including some kids dressed like Ant-Man
and this one that he exchanges a wink
with the fact that this opening
narration is Justified to be Scott
reading from his book makes us Wonder at
the end of the movie who is Scott
talking to then and also on the back of
Scott's lookout for the little guy book
our promotional quotes from Christine
Everhart and Bruce Banner Everhart was
the whih journalist from the first Iron
Man film who interrogated Scott in promo
shorts for the 2015 Ant-Man film Scott
picks up Cassie from jail which is where
Scott began the 2015 film just like Hank
kept a shrunken Soviet tank on his
keychain Cassie shrank this cop car its
alarm going off adorably Cassie's really
taking inspiration for both generations
of Ant-Man Hank Pym and Scott on the
drive home Cassie says she got arrested
while protesting the city clearing a
homeless encampment of people who had
lost their homes in the blip referring
to the people got dusted back just to
find their homes already occupied
creating this housing crisis Spider-Man
far from home and the flag Smashers plot
line and the Falcon Winter Soldier
introduced the concept of the blip
reversal wreaking havoc in terms of
causing limited sources like housing and
food and this shows that it's an ongoing
issue Cassie also says Dad a guy dressed
like a bee tried to kill me in my room
when I was six
setting up Darren's return in this movie
is Modoc Scott also finds out that
Cassie has her own suit which she is not
pleased about Scott plays a clip from
his audiobook during this drive
Hulk turned me into a baby will I be a
baby forever a little after that a
raccoon from space showed up I don't
think he knew my name I was just happy
to meet a raccoon who could talk yes
more nods to Avengers endgame Scott
meeting rocket and win their time travel
experiments resulted in Scott coming
back as a baby this reminds us of how
they accidentally invented a kind of
immortality when you think about it or
at least slow aging which becomes
important when they're super intelligent
ants aged a thousand years in a day in
this movie thank you to betterhelp for
sponsoring this video movies and TVs can
be great escapism but when it's time to
face things head on better help is here
to help better help is the world's
largest therapy service and it's 100
online with better help you can tap into
a network of over 30 000 licensed and
experienced therapists who can help you
with a wide range of issues to get
started just answer a few questions
about what you're looking for from
therapy and what your preferences are
better help will then match you with a
therapist from their Network that's
right for you after that talk to your
therapist however you feel comfortable
whether it's via text chat phone or
video call you can message your
therapist at any time and schedule live
sessions when it's convenient for you if
your therapist isn't the right fit for
any reason you can switch to a new
therapist at no additional charge Better
Health gives you the same level of
professionalism and quality you expect
from in office there therapy but with a
therapist whose custom pick for you with
scheduling flexibility and at a more
affordable price get 10 off your first
month at betterhelp.com new rockstars
that's
b-e-t-t-e-r-h-e-l-p.com Slash new
rockstars for 10 off your first month of
therapy now the Pim house is now located
on this street in San Francisco that's
actually not too far from where I live
at the innovate and the WASP remember
Hank had shrunken it down and moved it
by a beach but it's back now Hank saves
eight bucks by using old school pin
particles to enlarge a pizza which
director Peyton Reed confirmed is an eye
to that pizza hydration scene in Back to
the Future too as he directed The Making
of documentaries for the Back to the
Future sequels and was on set when they
shot that pizza scene oh boy oh boy mom
you sure can hydrate a pizza in Hank's
ear we see that he has this hearing aid
setting up his frequency and tangling
with the ants later on now over dinner
Cassie reminds Scott of previous Good
Deeds that he's done and moral stances
he's taken like when he hacked in a
Vista Corp remember that was the company
that Scott used to work for that was
screwing over its customers this is what
landed Scott in prison she brings up
Scott going to Germany to fight Captain
America and Civil War and Scott corrects
her that he fought with cap as an long
side cap because he was on team cap when
discussing Cassie's recent stint in jail
Hank says he would have just broken her
out with the ants referencing the scene
in Ant-Man when he used ants to smuggle
the suit into Scott's cell then as we
enter their basement lab right away
there are a ton of visual Clues pointing
to Cassie and Hank having geeked out
over ants in technology together
Cassie's Quantum satellite device has a
silver and bronze color like a vintage
stereo reflecting Hank's old school
design influence Scott sees their huge
ant farm and all the ants have these
helmets with these green lights the
display screen on the other side of the
room has the 3D image of an ant on it on
the death guard textbooks about ants Dr
Eleanor's common ants of California and
journey to the ants by Bert hole dobler
and Edward O Wilson Janet though is
suddenly super worried you know how
dangerous the quantum realm is that we
all do Mom nobody's going to the quantum
realm and she's ready to be concerned
since Modoc we learn later activates
Cassie's device they all get sucked in
while most of them get them getting
against their will I like the detail
that hope chooses to let go a heroic
move as she goes after her parents and
the rest of her family to save them now
as he tumbles down the rabbit hole of
the quantum realm Scott bumps into the
ant farm proving the ants got sucked
into and that glass breaks right there
and this is the moment the ants go
flying everywhere setting them on their
trajectory in this movie and uh
reminding us of that amazing Simpsons
episode deep space Homer
the family gets separated and Scott
slaps the chess piece onto his suit
compared to the last time we saw him in
in-game his suit in the opening sequence
now has a different chess piece and
that's because this is a form of
portable nanotech that contains the
entire suit similar to Tony Stark Tech
after giant Scott catches Cassie I love
how she proves she already knows how to
work this in her own suit by pressing
the button on Scott's glove to shrink it
back down he doesn't ask for orange
slices this time though so I guess he's
gotten more used to sizing up and down
hope and Hank realize where they are and
they shout Panic stricken for Janet
they're no doubt thinking about how they
only now just got Janet back after the
last time she was lost in the quantum
realm what Cassie thought was the sun
behind Scott has a stuttered movement as
they realize it's actually a predator I
just love the way this is revealed it
looks like the sun is moving like Glinda
the Good witch's bubble in The Wizard of
Oz Scott though enlarges he takes out
the paramecium thing and they end up
getting saved by the Freedom Fighters
meanwhile Janet explains to Hank you
weren't able to look deep enough not
through the void and subatomica she's
referring to the moment Hank and Janet
left the quantum realm in the 2018 film
when Peyton Reed hid a city in the
background that area with the chaotic
visuals must be what Janet was referring
to by the void and in the comics
subatomika is the name of a solar system
contained within the microverse Scott
and Cassie are taken to the freedom
fighter camp where they have to drink
the Ooze from this character veb whose
voice by David dust malcian who played
Kurt in the previous films I love what
you think is this threatening chant is
actually an encouragement by this Camp
basically saying join us join us join us
because they want to be able to
communicate with these newcomers this
ooze acts as a translator so they can
understand everyone in the quantum realm
it's almost like the Tardis translation
Matrix from Doctor Who William Jackson
Harper Chidi from the good place plays
the telepath quas his name is Scott Lang
he has seven holes
yeah that's right okay so one mouth two
nostrils two eyes two ears and an anus
and urethra that is nine holes I don't
know what's going on here maybe Scott
isn't counting his eyes because their
eyeballs plugged in them or maybe his
nostrils aren't being counted because
the nasal cavity leads to the same
esophagus and tracheal hole as the mouth
or maybe Scott just doesn't want the
society to know he's got lower parts
because he doesn't want to get probed so
he's just saying seven seven seven seven
seven and hope that they don't look for
other holes on him or maybe he's just
bad at math because you know in Paul
Red's eyes he's doing that thing from
clue like the OnePlus Two Plus One Plus
One the mandalorians Katie O'Brien plays
the freedom fighter leader gentura now
the comics gentura is from the planet
Kai and she's the niece of Queen gorilla
a love interest for the Hulk there are a
lot of interesting looking creatures
around this Camp including I'm most
fascinated now upon the rewatch these
guys with heads that are glowing colors
of the Infinity Stones why is this
important well after in-game directors
Joe and Anthony Russo confirmed in an
interview that Thanos only reduces
stones to the atomic level the stones
are still present in the universe so
somewhere in the quantum realm may be
atomized Stone particles and it is
possible that the atomized stones could
have flown in the quantum realm and
birthed these things Janet takes Hank
and hope to this Dune region where they
encounter this group of Nomads two of
them arrive on these flying ship-like
things that start as one splits and a
two just like the creature at the
beginning didn't Janet Aaron's Respect
by winning a fight and she gets this
trilobite that she telepathically
communicates to find out that it is
friendly now on their flight to Axia
they pass this landing pad that has an
image of Kang's face showing that the
Conqueror has fascistically begun to
stamp his Visage on everything Janet
leads Hank and hope to the city of Axia
where we learn this changes everything
we know about life Evolution our place
in the Galaxy holy [__]
that guy looks like broccoli yes
broccoli man is voiced by Graham box who
is the onset reader for the character
Crow and eternals theater bar that has a
distinct Star Wars Cantina Vibe and hope
gets hit on by the aforementioned
broccoli man because even the quantum
realm lady just can't get a drink in
peace they meet Janet's old flame krylar
in the comics krylar is a one and done
character from the planet Kai in the
microverse who goes by the Alias Steward
of all assassins and shows up in the
Incredible Hulk 156. similarly krylar in
this movie doesn't last too long before
Hank Pym enlarges that squid creature
delicacy that grabs him but for whatever
reason does not eat him on the flight
away Hank says at dinner with someone a
few times
name was Linda
it didn't work out so Linda was going to
be a hot scientist character played by
Jennifer Coolidge but the character was
cut according to Jeff loveness Tang
meanwhile since Modoc to hunt Scott and
Cassie from the freedom fighter camp in
the comics Modoc is aim technician
George Tarleton who gets mutated by The
Cosmic Cube Marvel Studios retcon Modoc
to be Darren cross Corey stole's villain
yellowjacket from the 2015 film his body
parts disproportionately shrunk after
being zipped down to the quantum realm
and yeah a bit of an uncanny valley
though I'm fairly certain upon watching
on Disney plus now the VFX artist did do
a bit of retexturing upgrade to Corey
stole's face a montage flashes back to
Darren and his defeat in the 2015 film
and then it picks back up with its
disfigured form in the quantum realm and
Kang restoring his body to his pale
creepy little butt and he becomes the
source of mockery for the rest of the
film now Peyton Reid talked in an
interview about the shot of Modoc being
reconstructed that quote that visual
effect shot where we show it was
something that shook us as very funny
his quick version and short of grotesque
one of my notes in that shot was like oh
that's really great but you need to see
a little bit more of his butt crack in
this also notice Modoc has this heart
rate monitor on his chat I said later
flat lines when he dies he also has that
Crystal on his forehead to fire a beam
at Scott entertain them for Kang Janet
finally tells hope and hanker history
with Kang to conqueror and we see in the
flashback that Janet tells Kang about
the last time she saw hope a scene that
we saw in the 2018 film prologue and
Kang says time
it's not what you think it is it's a
cage
it does everything it can
break you it's not until you free
yourself from it that you see just how
small it always was she says Kang ship
could travel the Multiverse and Hank
asks Multiverse
as in alternate dimensions
parallel realities
but it's real
just like we theorized Janet recounts
how after saving each other she and Kang
agreed to help each other rebuild and
reactivate the multiversal engine core
of his ship we don't know how many the
other kangs have this kind of Technology
but we have to assume none of them do or
they all do now that he remains is out
of the picture but they have this kind
of truce where they check each other's
infinite power over the time stream kind
of mutually assured destruction but this
gang the Conqueror went rogue he refused
to play by any of their rules he was
disciplined for it Janet says his ship
is neurokinetic connected to his
thoughts and this sequence uses the
sacred timeline imagery from Loki but it
shows this Kang to conqueror tearing it
apart it's amazing to go through this
frame by frame because Janet sees a
field of exploding planets one planet
that has a blue glowing wound with a
smoldering red core at the center of it
Janet says I felt what he had done we
get a quick shot of Kang with his eyes
glowing and the lines on his face
glowing right where his scars are as he
blasts a beam from his fist at these
fleeing victims in the Smoky burnt
Forest these victims are some
civilization of people wearing green
clothes including horribly a mother
hugging her child Just Before
Destruction hits and bluefire throws
some guys off their feet his fire burns
through one man's face before he turns
to Ash and remember when we saw Kane
crashed into the quantum realm in the
earlier parts of this flashback with
Janet he is wearing the same kind of
green clothes that these people are
wearing these were his neighbors or his
home people which is even more messed up
he probably knew them and they trusted
him so either he started his destructive
Conquest with his home civilization or
he would migrate from civilization to
civilization timeline to timeline
assimilating him with that group of
people kind of like those birds that lay
their eggs and other birds nests and
then one day snap he just starts
massacring them all Janet describes what
she saw entire world
higher timelines gone
like they never even existed and now the
plans that we saw before completely
explode as the giant blue beams surged
into their surfaces and we zoom out to
see these plants are contained within a
single strand of a sacred timeline a
strand that now bursts leaving several
burnt ends and the last thing we see is
a huge bundle of strands all exploding
in a flash of white we cut back to Janet
who still holds onto the ship
goes on her face as more of the Kang's
memories unfold unseen by the audience
Bank Sees In Her Eyes that she knows who
he is and immediately flips into
manipulation mode when it's clear he's
not going to convince Janet just to
leave with him he frames his master plan
in a single word win so Janet disables
his core by enlarging it Beyond use with
pemdisks it's interesting that Janet
hung onto these maybe for a rainy day or
maybe deep down she did not 100 trust
Kang and she knew that she would need to
keep them just in case and she makes the
heroic sacrifice of trapping them both
down there indefinitely now meanwhile
Kang introduces himself to Scott who
confidently tells him that he's an
Avenger Kang says that he's killed
Avengers before and for the second time
of this movie Scott is confused with
someone else you're not the one with the
hammer Thor
we get confused a lot similar body types
Kang has specifically killed Thor which
I speculated might have been right
before Thor sparked Vision to life since
vision and his Multiverse mind would
pose potentially the greatest threat to
Kang in another timeline when Kang
mentions Janet he actually looks hurt
when he realizes she didn't tell anyone
about him he's probably been obsessing
about it for years just like he couldn't
get all the people he murdered out of
his head again his neighbors he killed
everyone at the cookout and King
explains that he knows how all of time
ends me
a lot of me they exiled me
down here they're afraid of me it's
pretty similar to what his variant he
remains says in Loki and
if you think I'm
evil well
this way
till you meet bye variance now to
compare these two while he remains was
extremely animated jumping in and out of
his death chair Majors performances Kang
is more rigid Regal and what the actor
describes as no moves wasted he drew
upon historical figures like Julius
Caesar Genghis Khan Alexander the Great
so then Kang threatens Cassie which gets
Scott to help him shrink the core and
King opens a portal to the site Scott
dives into the probability storm begins
splitting into variance which Modoc
describes as Schrodinger's Box Scott
being the cat in that metaphor referring
to Erwin Schrodinger's thought
experiment using an unobserved system
showdinger's cat was first referenced in
the MCU back on Eric selvic's chalkboard
and Thor the Dark World this is also
described by Bill Foster in the 2018
Ant-Man the wasp in other words the
object in question would be both in and
out of phase with multiple parallel
realities now the bands of the score
have some writing on them the language
based on circles which actually you can
see recording in other parts of the
quantum realm it's interesting how all
this is connected to Kang which makes
sense historically as an Invader one of
the signs of imperialism is the invading
Force established is a new language a
new written language that the colonized
people then have to adopt one of Scott's
variances himself if he never became an
Avenger in state of Baskin Robbins or if
he was just an Avenger who also just
continued to work at Baskin Robbins
actually off screen you can hear another
Scott asking
now win one of the Scotts sizes up he
unravels into ribbons which looks a lot
like what Wanda maximoff does to read
Richards and Multiverse Madness so you
gotta imagine it's very painful I
imagine this is just what it looks like
when you just get unraveled out of
existence like all of us are bundles of
sacred timeline ribbons all tied
together in a knot what Miguel O'Hara
calls the nodes of the web at the
spider-verse so in order to prune
someone out of existence you're
basically unraveling that knot now this
scene shows that the Scott Marriotts put
their helmets up out of fear while our
Scott stays unhelmitted this shows them
as more courageous and determined than
the others but it also shows the viewer
to follow him in this scene without
getting confused also worth mentioning
that the very first double that steps
away from Scott when he first splits
turns and faces the other direction
which tells us that that doppelganger
her what defined him was his choice to
turn away from the drama and run away in
fear but the thought of
say one constant that draws all of these
Alternatives back together it's one
thing they have in common and so all of
them need to get drawn back together
even the ones who turned away in fear
because you also need to bring your fear
with you meanwhile hope performs her own
heroic dive to save Scott and based on
Instagram photos there was a deleted
scene from the section that would have
shown hope facing her own identity
crisis in this probability storm facing
variants of herself as a mother with
children in her arms but yes the scene
was removed so after shrinking the core
back down Kang tells hope hello
Jollibee which was Janet's nickname for
her it's a creepy way of indicating that
he knows hope and rightness of how much
he and Janet shared in their time
together so Kang takes the core and
Janet back to his Fortress where he
projects the sacred timeline around the
room starting with a ring in his hand
colliding endless incursions I saw the
Multiverse and he was dying more because
of them he remains also felt that what
he was doing was for the greater good at
the expense of all the other kangs so
it's kind of a running theme that each
one thinks his plan is the correct one
this inability to work together puts the
kangs in direct contrast to the united
front Scott just put up with his
variants Kang projects one ring over the
other with branches veering downward and
colliding with these flashes these
represent incursions when he who remains
first revealed the Multiverse in his
origin story he depicted it by one ring
floating atop another now we see how the
sacred timeline's eruption upon Soviet
killing he remains affects another
sacred timeline that event as well as
Peter Parker and Doctor Strange's spell
going awry and strange and want to
maximoff dreamwalking and Multiverse of
Madness these are all examples of
incursions and it's interesting upon
watching Spider-Man across the
spider-verse they use the same white
glowing tree branch imagery King blames
the other kings in the dynasty for their
childish meddling and says you have no
idea
what I have lost and I will burn them
out of time so when we see King vaporize
people in his mind he is burning them
out of time like cauterizing a wound
leaving his scar like the ones on his
face we're left with the question of
what Kang loss really you could say he's
doing all this for his long-lost love of
ravona rensslayer we might get the
answer in Loki season two but again with
all the John of the majors drama who
knows what they're really doing with
that show Hank meanwhile is saved by his
aunt Farm the ants time dilated a
thousand years in a single day meaning
they slipped into a Time Vortex and
built the socialistic technocratic
society the best parts of Ant-Man films
are the ants I will always say that over
and over again and these ants in a way
neutralize Kang's advantage of
Technology hundreds of years in the
future because Kang's chosen system of
governance is an archaic military
dictatorship though he does get away
from them later we'll talk about that in
a bit really I just love the futuristic
design of the ants architecture that you
can see now that is streaming in high
definition they essentially built a vast
ant colony Towers like the ones Hank
kept them in and these towers start from
the the top and work their way down as
ants instinctively start from the ground
level and burrow deeper and deeper into
the Earth Kang mobilizes his Fortress to
depart as the quantum realm with his
entire Army declaring today
we conquer
eternity and the dynasty of cage and
Cassie Cuts him off conquer eternity
just interesting choice of words
eternity is part of the cosmic entity
hierarchy but I don't know if he was
referring to that entity of Eternity but
more importantly Kang mentions the
dynasty whom we meet in the first
post-credits scene and will be the
Kang's The Avengers have to face in
Avengers the King Dynasty in 2025 we'll
see if Jonathan Majors is the one
playing all of these kangs in the future
giant Scott arrives assaulty Kang's
Fortress stomping on his forces
mirroring how Kang will later stomp on
his head by trying to crush an ant we
see how Scott picks up a disshaped piece
of a building and uses it as a shield
shield he later wedges into Kang's Rings
like Captain America Steve Rogers wood
bringing Scott full circle with his
reference membership on team cap from
Civil War any cannonballs into these
rings and he breaks them now we have to
admit that Scott's aggression in the
scene is just a bit odd hey we had a
deal you took my daughter you lied to me
according to an unnamed VFX artist who
opened up about their process working on
this film a lot of Scott's action in
this final battle was fully animated
from scratch they said there were times
when we were creating an actor's entire
action Ant-Man moving across something
and you just think why didn't they film
it the right way or how they wanted it
in the first place why are we having to
redo and recreate why do we have to
Frankenstein together in actors
performance so yes we watch giant Scott
Crush through everything that might have
just all been created by a VFX artist
with Paul Red's voice from just some
other voice session and they just
stitched it together all in
post-production another artist blamed
the fact that resources were diverted to
Black Panther wakanda forever which was
in post-production at the same time as
quantumania recording that artist quote
in terms of priority what kind of
forever was definitely at the top of the
list all the money went to that all the
best resources went to that so I think
Marvel Studios has learned a lot of
lessons for putting too much on their
plates and in February 2023 returning
Disney CEO Bob Iger and Marvel Studios
had Kim feige both implied a scale back
and output now Kang could have used that
Multiverse core to power his ship chair
alone and escape the quantum realm
without going to all this trouble but he
fails why because he got too greedy he
wanted to bring his entire Fortress and
his entire fleet with him to wage war on
all the kanks because he insisted on
bringing all of his stuff with him he
gave Scott and the others enough time to
stop him his selfishness here directly
contrasts with Janet's selflessness
earlier and willingly trapping herself
in the quantum realm giant Scott
celebrates with giant Cassie father and
daughter finally on the same level
restoring their bond and Cassie's fate
that her dad will do the right thing
Cassie says she's hungry craves a lime
to which Scott says Citrus it's weird I
know calling back the running joke of
Scott wanting orange slices whenever he
goes big does anyone have any orange
slices and he even had orange slices in
his hand when Clint came back with a
baseball glove in Avengers end game and
so Kang finally letting his rage boil
over floats down to the battle on this
disc and vaporizes everyone in sight veb
gets the holes he so desperately wanted
which he uses to Kirby some Quantum
knots but Kang kills solom and gentura
is forced to retreat and we briefly see
one sentient building holding the other
as it dies in its arms just oddly
heartbreaking to watch Cassie finally
Masters the jump tap and she Scott and
hope by Kang Hank's Aunt save the day
though swarming him and Darren takes
Cassie's advice to stop being a dick and
he redeems himself just this shot of
Corey stole his face bursting into the
shield looks so good and Vivid as does
Kang's look of shock and disgust back at
Modoc probably ruminating on the fact
that he's always getting betrayed like
dude maybe your managerial style is the
reason people keep going on your team
now the ants pick apart Kang's armor and
carry him away and it's never exactly
shown how Kang escaped these ants so
that he could later confront Scott in
the throne room but a dictator with
super advanced technology I don't know
maybe he flipped one of these
technocratic Society ants into turning
on the others they watched Modoc die and
his heart rate monitor turns red into
flat lines and at least I died an
Avenger again this whole journey for
Scott you could say was to put him
through a ringer to truly earn his
status as an Avenger and notice in this
moment modok's Crown is broken and his
face is bruised and bleeding the VFX and
character design just looks a lot better
and I just think it's because with that
Crown broken there's no frame boxing in
his face giving him more flat appearance
here's more Dimension and texture to his
face Janet uses the quantum core to open
a portal home but Scott notices Kang
approaching pushes Cassie in so that he
can stay behind fight can keep him out
king and Scott fight one on one and I do
love it when an epic third act battle
just boils down to a simple fist fighter
sword duel Scott is outmatched but he
hangs in there I don't have to win we
both just have to leave hope returns it
helps Scott destroy the core with red
and blue pin particles pushing Kang in
the vortex that creates and shrinking
him out of sight presumably not dead
he's probably stuck in an endless
probability storm where unlike Scott
it's just gonna be really hard for Kang
to cooperate with his variants yet one
day our man is gonna figure it out and I
believe that is going to be the ultimate
Kang who Lords over battle world and
Secret Wars Cassie uses her Quantum
realm telescope to locate the last known
spot of the portal and I guess is able
to reopen it all this happens real fast
and it's just a bit too easy but there
might be a reason why because this
film's epilogue doesn't really leave
things all neatly type with Scott like
he remains haunted by the consequences
of defeating Kang to conqueror fearing
the Kang Dynasty Beyond him now I
theorize that these final minutes of the
film are part of a similar relation or
warp timeline a kind of nightmare
scripted by the Kang Dynasty because
Scott Loops back into the routine that
he started the film in but now there are
all kinds of noticeable changes like
Reuben now knows who he is exactly
pedestrians are all acting super odd
giving him odd eye contact there's like
weird little glitches in The Matrix
where he looks at a specific pair of
extras that suddenly appear in front of
him his eyes seem to linger on people
wearing specific shades of purple and
green like there are purple balloons at
Cassie's party there's a green cake
these are the colors of King's clothes
and his armor it kind of feels like
Scott is in a sort of Truman Show
scenario or Frozen in a sitcom that he
can't escape which would explain why
these movies keep opening with old
sitcom theme songs playing he's a
comedian sitcom star being welcomed back
welcome back welcome back welcome back
to this narrative Loop written for him
by Architects controlling every aspect
of his life Architects thrilled that he
did away with their pesky Exile and we
know from set photos taken in January
2023 that this sidewalk shot with Paul
Rudd carrying the pink kickbox was part
of reshoots taped only a month before
the film's release while the studio is
in the midst of this big scale back plan
that might have resulted in this movie's
rushed ending that would omit any Young
Avengers set up for Cassie Lang so then
we get the first of two post credit
scenes where exactly what Kang
threatened and what Scott feared comes
to pass an arena filled with gang
variants teleporting in from squares of
white light all shouting and talking
animatedly the scene is taken directly
from some famous Comics imagery 1988's
Avengers 292 written by Walt Simonson
penciled by John bashima which is really
a Neymar story but it features a cutaway
in which Kang is summoned before the
Council of kings and we see three VIP
kangs barrel ramatut immortus and a
futuristic suited Kang conferred by the
director and screenwriter to be a
version of scarlet Centurion you'll know
this has a robotic body telling us that
this one might have survived some nasty
battle with other Marvel heroes to
require such cybernetic enhancement
Nemours says the beginning
[Music]
everything
take weave
let's stop wasting time reopens the
window to show the flowing sacred
timeline outside with split branches
sneaking in every direction forming what
we assume are incursions the mortise
turns away from the window saying how
many did you call
oh
us and we're back in the arena pit where
more and more Kings teleport in most are
wearing some combination of green and
purple robes but one wears dark gray
armor one wears a slim corporate suit
I'm pretty sure is Mr Griffin CEO of
Kang Enterprises whose alternate reality
version of Avengers Tower was pruned to
the void in Loki episode 5. there are a
lot more they're all getting pumped up
and what we're seeing here is the Kang
Dynasty and thousands of kangs that the
Avengers will face in the fifth Avengers
film Avengers the Kang Dynasty the
second post credit scene ties into Loki
season 2. we find ourselves at a 1901
exhibition with some steampunky looking
invention on the stage the banner on the
side reads Victor timely and his
astounding temporal Marvels major struts
out on stages Victor timely and
announces to the audience
is
every
thing it shapes our lives but perhaps we
can shape
it so Victor timely is another one of
Kang's incarnations when Kang went back
in time to 1901 and founded the town of
timely Wisconsin serving as the town's
mayor and establishing it as an
industrial center by teaching them
robotics it was at the site of timely
that Kang built his Fortress city of
chronopolis timely of course is a nod to
Marvel Comics history the company
previously went by the name timely
comics in this scene watching Victor
timely make the speech are Loki and
Mobius in Period appropriate disguise we
see more evidence of Kang and the Loki
season 2 trailer but rumor has it there
may be some reshoots underway for Loki
season 2. the jury's still out but my
theory for this scene is that Victor
timely was the same variant as he
remains and that we are seeing the
origin of the TVA and all the people
surrounding Loki and Mobius are the
first generation of employees of the TVA
because you got to start somewhere hey
thanks for watching this re-breakdown of
Ant-Man that was quantumania how did you
feel re-watching this movie is it as
good as it was back in February is it a
bit worse you can support our Network
shop like this miles Brown's most
Multiverse dive shirt follow me on
Instagram and Twitter at eavos subscribe
to the Deep dive subscribe to the break
room follow new rockstars And subscribe
to new rockstars or breakdowns and
everything you love thanks for watching
bye
[Music]